son son son man Marvel's rebooting
Spider-Man and the ending to this comic
is amazing right this is God I I'm so
excited to see where this comic goes so
this is Ultimate Spider-Man number one
and this comic basically opens up in
January now the reason why that's the
case is because the Ultimate Universe or
at least this new Ultimate Universe
going forward will be much like the old
one in the sense that it's kind of the
answer to the question what if
superheroes existed in this real world
what would it look like and so you'll
see a lot of reflection of what goes on
in the world right now reflected in the
comics so it's really really cool right
Jonathan Hickman does an amazing job
with this so a few things to know number
one Peter Parker never became Spider-Man
and Peter Parker's got kids right now
the reason why Peter Parker never became
Spider-Man was covered during the story
ultimate Invasion which we have covered
and you'll find a link to that at the
ending of this video but the important
thing here is that in effect Peter
Parker as most of you guys know gets
bitten by a radioactive spider in his
teenage years and he goes on to become
Spider-Man that was stopped and because
he was never bitten by a radioactive
spider he never became Spider-Man he
just grew up as a guy that eventually
got a job at The Daily Bugle now his two
kids it's kind of cool right Richard and
may of course being named after members
of his family that Richard is named
after his father Richard Parker and his
daughter is named after Aunt May right
May Parker there's actually a reason for
that so you guys are going to find this
is going to very very closely not really
mirror but have Concepts from what
you've seen in the Tom Holland
Spider-Man movies from the MCU of course
Mary Jane Watson is here as well and
basically life is great for them right
like they got a family and they they do
their thing and everything's for the
most part pretty cool but what is up
happening and one of the things that I
want you guys to notice here is that
there's this kind of ball that may
Parker has in her possession right it
almost looks like a crystal ball now of
course Peter Parker takes that away and
says that's not a toy keep that in the
back of your head because that is going
to be stupendously important by the time
we get to the end of this comic and I'm
curious to see if anybody can figure it
out right as you're watching this video
leave a comment down below and let me
know if you're able to figure out what
the deal is with that Crystal Ball but
what you end up doing is transitioning
to the Daily Bugle now for the most part
Life In The Daily Bugle is exactly as
you would expect J Jonah Jameson is
still a dick he still yells at people
all the time and we all still love him
for it right like Peter Parker is still
here doing his Peter Parker thing but
there's a big difference a big caveat
because there is another office that is
ran by the managing editor and this guy
is Ben Parker Uncle Ben never
died Uncle Ben was never killed right
he's very much alive as soon as I saw
this I was like really right I literally
just sat up in my seat I was like okay
let's see where this goes Jonathan
Hickman now one of the things that's
kind of funny here is that seemingly J
Jonah Jameson and Ben Parker have been
working together for decades right like
20 maybe 30 years at this point and in
fact when Peter Parker shows up here he
and Ben Parker are supposed to be going
on some kind of a walk or basically
meeting and talking and so on and so
forth but there's a kind of back and
forth here that I absolutely adore right
like Peter Parker shows up here he's
like Uncle Ben are you ready and benin's
like I was ready 15 minutes ago Peter
why are you late and he's like well it's
probably because I was neither on time
nor early right a Parker arrives
precisely when he means to like I love
that right and so the response have been
that's cute the response of J Jonah
Jameson kids these days always being
cute always being clever and Ben's
response never clever enough to show up
on time and the response of jjon and
Jameson but clever nonetheless there is
a strong camaraderie here between these
guys that I love and I never realized I
needed it until now K I was Jonathan
Hickman you did a fantastic job right
and even then like Peter's just kind of
like you guys should have your own show
right so it's awesome the way that it's
done right like Peter Parker J Jonah
Jameson Ben Parker I mean it's just it's
just this amazing little thing and so
what you do is you end up finding out
that of course J Jonah Jameson in a lot
of ways much like what we're familiar
with with the the main line or main
Marvel Universe Comics really in more
recent years J Jonah Jameson I wouldn't
go so far as to say is like a father
figure for Peter because of course
that's really what Uncle Ben is more
like a mentor because he pulls him aside
for a second and he's like where's your
tie and he's like well I never really
wear a tie I really didn't I really
don't even own one and the response of J
Jonah Jameson you have to wear a tie
right take off your jacket and he
presents him with a tie and he kind of
sits around and talks to him right he's
like have I ever told you about how much
we love to sit around and talk about our
feelings your uncle and I and it's a
really really touching moment right
because J Jon and Jameson says your
uncle is the toughest son of a gun that
I've ever met asking if he's okay is
kind of like asking about the durability
of stone or some other geological
remnant of another time saying that how
about you and I regardless of how it
appears he's doing keep a close lookout
for any cracks that we might see can we
agree to that and the response of Peter
is yes right so very much ben Parker is
an old school guy and so what you end up
getting is this moment where Peter is
talking to Ben and he kind of asked him
the question like everybody's wondering
if if you're doing okay like everybody
wants to know how you're doing the
response have been everyone is not
wondering if I'm okay Peter everyone
doesn't care we work at the bugle so you
and me we're in the words business if if
there's something you want to say don't
hide your intent just go ahead and say
it then everyone quote unquote will
respect you because you did and his
response fair enough like I'm worried
about you Ben asks why and he says what
do you mean why you won't talk talk
about what happened you haven't said
anything not one word about how you're
doing or how you feel and so what's
really really interesting here is in
this conversation Ben talks about the
idea that when he arrived on the
doorstep of Ben and may Parker 15 years
ago following the death of his parents
that they took a man as their own and
raised him as their own son but never
tried to replace his parents and he says
it's been a long time but has one day
gone by that you didn't think about them
is there one day that it doesn't hurt
that they're gone the response of Peter
no the response of Ben then you know
exactly how I feel Aunt May died now
here's the big difference here it's not
like the main Marvel Universe where Aunt
May was killed in the same way that
Uncle Ben was killed in the comics in
the sense that like you know Peter
allowed some mugger to run by you know
because the guy was ripping him off or
whatever you know it's one of these
things where she was killed in the Stark
explosion in Ultimate Invasion so for
those of you guys who aren familiar with
that right kind of touching back a
little bit on Ultimate Invasion because
this would be a Lynch pin for most
everything that goes forward in the
future of the Ultimate Universe so I
highly suggest you watch it the long and
short is that there was an alternate
reality version of Reed Richards called
The Maker he came from the original
Ultimate Universe which doesn't exist
anymore so you can largely ignore its
existence but what the maker wanted to
do is he wanted to recreate his original
universe so he traveled to this reality
and then just started changing things
but one of the things he did is he
formed the Illuminati which operated
behind the scenes in the absence of the
maker who was the leader of the group
The Illuminati started basically
orchestrating events behind the scenes
to kind of secure power consolidate
power different things like that one of
the events that had transpired in
Ultimate invasion is that the Stark
building was blown up to make it look
like a stark accident when the reality
here is it was an orbital satellite that
was fired in order to blow the building
to Pieces the result is that while Tony
Stark is seemingly believed to be dead
even though we know he's not
that explosion killed a boatload of
people in the city of New York so it's
really one of these things where it
seems like annually they get together
and they mourn the loss of these people
and so what you end up getting here is
the realization that Aunt May was killed
in this explosion not only that Matt
Murdoch seemingly never became Daredevil
he just became a priest within the
Catholic church right he's referred to
as like Father Murdoch and so while he
gives this speech to everybody and
explains everything that's going on or
at least kind of talking about the loss
but for the most part also kind of ties
it to Ultimate Invasion for us as the
reader that he actually says there is a
person here who wants to speak the
people that he lost here were Emily and
Norman Osborne this is their son Harry
so Norman Osborne the Green Goblin he's
dead gone he's not in the picture
anymore right he was killed as well but
something that I want you to notice as
Harry stands up and he makes this speech
right the idea that they come together
and he says word We Gather here every
year in order to honor the lives of
those who were lost right to remind them
them that we love them and to remind
ourselves that as a city we will endure
right but he says it's just not enough
and I'm not sure any of us would be
expected to live with it there's an
anger here that Harry Osborne has a
deep-seated anger over this loss and it
will manifest itself because what you do
is you pick up at The Daily Bugle and
literally as uh as Peter and Ben get
back here J Jonah Jameson is pitching a
fit throws papers in the air walks out
and says I quit right like I'm done just
leave and so at that point Ben's like
okay Peter like go to your desk keep
your head down we'll catch up later when
Ben gets into the boardroom you end up
having Robbie Robertson right who is
like the second in command to J Jonah
Jameson right he basically says like so
here's the rub man like between the
board and the advertisers and folks like
that they don't like how it is that
we're covering the Stark explosion
advertisers are threatening to pull out
we're going to lose money and we'll end
up shutting down and because news is a
profit driven institution we have to
keep the advertisers right above
anything else the question has to be
asked is the news that we're reporting
and how we're reporting it is it keeping
the coffers full truth comes second and
so Robbie Robertson says J Jonah Jameson
just didn't really care for the changes
and so he quit then Ben Parker asked
Robbie the question how do you feel
about them Robbie his response I'm two
years away from maxing out my pension
and I feel like it would just be a good
idea so at the end of the day Robbie's
like I'm just going forward with it now
here's the thing right this is GNA piss
off some Spider-Man fans because Robbie
Robbie Robertson has a small but very
dedicated fan base and Robbie Robertson
is nothing if not a man devoted to the
truth in the main Marvel universe so
seeing the Ultimate Universe kind of
flip him on its head and say I mean do I
agree with what they're doing it doesn't
really matter what matters is I'm two
years away from maxing out my pension
and potentially retiring I don't really
much care for doing doing what's right
or wrong I care about making it to the
finish line and calling it a day so some
folks will probably be a little offended
by that I'm curious to see how people
are going to respond to it right but the
fact remains here that Robbie Robertson
says because of all these things right
you know the advertisers and so on we're
making some changes right at the behest
of both the board and broader leadership
in general and where Ben asked the
question how do you think I should feel
about that his response or at least a
statement comes from the Kingpin Wilson
Fisk who says you should be pleased at
your good fortune after all nature abor
a vacuum and it's like what what what do
you mean Mr fist right and his response
is Jameson's out now the paper needs new
leadership you are the obvious choice
and so I suppose congratulations are in
order Mr Parker it seems you've got your
promotion that's if you want the job of
course and if you can tow the line so it
seems like Wilson Fisk basically owns
The Daily Bugle right he owns an entire
newspaper now of course this in a lot of
ways is an allegory probably to Elon
Musk owning Twitter but the fact remains
here right like everybody looks at Ben
Parker to see his reaction and all he
does is smile walk out of the office and
join jjon and Jon in the elevator and
leave now I will say this if if Jonathan
Hickman which I couldn't imagine him
doing this if Jonathan Hickman had
written it in such a way to where he had
crafted this situation where Ben Parker
just kind of dropped his head in sadness
and said okay it would have pissed off
the Spider-Man universe to no end so it
would have been abs absolutely crazy but
the point is that later on as Wilson
Fisk is getting out of his vehicle he's
suddenly attacked out of nowhere by the
Green Goblin who obviously is Harry
Osborne here right now we only see him
for a second because what you do is you
transition to the bar with no name which
is an obvious allegory to the bar in the
main Mar Universe which is a sign for
like Wizards and witches and people who
specify or who specialize in Magic and
all that kind of stuff and only people
with magical abilities can access it
that's clearly not the cas case here
this is just a bar out there in New York
that just doesn't have a name on it but
the fact remains that you have this
really interesting debate between uh J
Jonah Jameson and Benjamin Parker where
they kind of go back and forth right and
they talk about all this stuff
everything that's happened so far and
the thing about J Jonah Jameson is he
kind of laughs at Ben Parker because Ben
Parker is like we should do our own
thing right like we should launch our
own news organization you know and he's
like the easy thing about this like we
do it right and where J Jonah Jameson is
like what is look like doing it right
the response to B is it's easy we tell
the truth and J Jonah Jameson just kind
of laughs out loud because he makes this
argument and he says there's no room for
truth in news right people know the
truth people ignore the truth people
want the facts they want to hear right
he's like he almost takes a page out of
like The Newsroom right where he says
like in this day and age right in this
era right now people choose the facts
they want so whether or not you present
them with the truth is irrelevant but
Benjamin Parker has a a lot more faith
in people than J Jonah Jameson does
because his stance is no right sure
there are people out there that choose
the facts they want but we can convince
them by showing them what's really going
on out there bringing honest to goodness
real truthful journalism we can make
that work but at the end of the day the
stance of J Jonah Jameson and even the
wisdom and experience he brings to the
table cannot be denied there is truth in
him making the statement that there's no
truth in the news and no news in truth
and so he's like it's a dirty business
that's just the way that it is this is
not me bringing my personal beliefs to
the table it's 30 years working in this
industry and watching how people absorb
the news that informs this belief system
and so he says how about this right we
promise that we simply won't lie that's
what we promise to do we simply just
don't lie to people now this is where
the ending that I was telling you about
gets crazy because what you do here is
you have Peter Parker who walks in on
the two two of these guys and just
starts talking to them right he
basically word got around to him that
they ultimately left the Daily Bugle and
they offer him a job right and he's like
do you guys have any money you know and
they're like that's a day two problem
Peter you know he says tonight I am a
man who is right with the world right
jjon and Jameson's like we'll worry
about the cash later on and he's like
think it over Peter right and so Peter
asked this question he was like Ben I
got to know right like how did you blow
your whole life up in one afternoon and
then just start a new one and the
response of is because there is nothing
else I have nothing else right you're a
grown man Peter Parker you're not my
child anymore or at least what would be
my child Aunt May's dead it's just me a
man in the world by myself I can start
and stop a new life every day if I
choose to but the reality is the choice
was easy right like either I stay as
just a guy out here in the world working
for a newspaper publishing news in a way
that I don't agree with because the man
who runs the show demands that I tow the
party line or I quit and I basically do
what I believe to be the right right
thing for myself because in Uncle Ben's
case at his age all that matters is
speaking his truth and being his true
self because that's all he has left it's
very easy for us as people and even like
this personal honesty and living the
life that we want to live it's very easy
for all of that to fall to the Wayside
in the face of life's struggles and in
the face of life's responsibilities
Peter's dealing with that right now
because he's like I have a wife I have
children I can't just uproot quit a
full-time job and leave and go to to
this place right just go do a thing
because it's like my destiny or
something along those lines and Uncle
Ben starts to pick up on the fact that
Peter is not talking about the Daily
Bugle the job that he has there and
working for Uncle Ben and working for
jjon and Jameson there's something else
going on here right and he was like you
know what's the deal he's like are you
and MJ okay right and the response of
Peter I mean yeah I'm great she's great
you know and she says that that you know
I think she deserves better than me but
she disagrees which makes it even better
right you know because she's with me
because she loves me you know just he
says for the longest time I thought
something was wrong with my life been
that something was wrong with me I can't
really explain it but now I just know
that I've been right all along and I
don't know what to do the life that I'm
living is not the life that I was
supposed to live and the response of Ben
is have you ever heard the saying that
in action is action right the response
of Peter yes and so Ben and turn says
that's just a garbage way of saying
don't spend your life waiting for
something to happen make it happen right
and he says I love you son but if you're
walking around half asleep anesthetize
by your own life then it's time to wake
up and so Peter of course says good
night to his kids and he says good night
to Mary Jean Watson and and he talks
about how he needs to pursue a grander
purpose and she asked the question does
this change things between us he says
absolutely not she's like then go do
your thing and so what you do is you
pick up with Peter on a rooftop right
and he's holding this Crystal Ball in
his hand and what it does is it jumps
back to the night before right before
this comic picked up right and you get
this message right this is for Peter
Parker right and he says hello if this
is gone as I'd hoped I am speaking with
Peter Parker it's Tony Stark Ironman or
at least a holographic projection of him
and he says my name is Tony Stark and
while it's likely that you know my
father's name you've probably never
heard of me now of course because Tony
Stark was blamed for the explosion in
New York everybody knows his name right
he says I'm sending this to you from 6
months into the future there was an
attempt on my and my companions lives
and we only had seconds to escape before
the orbital platform fired and that's
when Peter's like wait we never heard
anything about an orbital platform
firing at the building right so that's
when he starts to realize he's only got
half the equation here and so Tony
continues on and he says so he went to
the only safe place that I could think
of and he says I'm sorry I can't be more
specific than I'm about to be but we
have to be careful because this world is
more complicated and dangerous than you
could ever believe and there's a
component of Faith to this that frankly
is unavoidable and he says all I ask is
that you please listen carefully and he
says inside this right this ball that he
has in his hand is a picot tech stealth
suit to mask your identity and a
bioorganic catalyst necessary for you to
undergo a posthuman transformation and
Peter of course flabbergast it says what
in the world is this supposed to mean
the response of Iron Man 20 years ago
you were supposed to be bitten by a
radioactive spider this would have given
you amazing powers and with them you
would have become one of Earth's most
prominent superheroes instead a great
evil traveled through time and erased
almost all the heroes of this world from
existence you were one of them he did
this so that he and his Confederates I.E
the Illuminati could treat Earth as a
kind of experiment an exercise in
creating a society that could be
perfectly directed and controlled I am
repeating this with six others like you
and in 6 months if I've done this
correctly I will exit this room to find
an earth that has regained its Heroes
and together we will free the world it
is my greatest hope that you are among
our number and of course he says you are
supposed to have a different life Peter
Parker you are supposed to protect the
innocent save lives and Inspire the
citizens of this world to be their best
selves and instead all of that was taken
from you so what it does is it jumps to
this current moment right now right
because Peter's kind of flashing back
between this when the last thing that
Iron Man asked him is do you want that
life back right this ball this Crystal
Ball opens up in his hands and when it
does a smaller ball comes out and what
he finds here is a little tube with a
radioactive spider the exact spider that
was supposed to bite him and he kind of
recollects on this idea Uncle B telling
him if you believe that you've been
anesthetized by your own life it's time
to wake up the response of MJ if you
believe you're meant for a greater
Destiny then go and get it and so Peter
Parker takes the spider out of the vial
puts it on his hand and finds himself
bitten and officially becomes Spider-Man
it's amazing with that being said guys
we're going to bring this to an end I
loved this comic it's a slow burn but
it's great if you guys need to get
caught up on Ultimate Invasion and how
we got to this point make sure you guys
click the link to this playlist and I
will catch you all later peace